[Music]
hello everyone thank you very much for
coming to our session we'll talk today
about how Google protects your data
arrests and transit
my name is Ulsan Lee I'm a product
manager in the security and privacy area
it's specifically working on key
management and I'm here with Maya
Katsuragi who is working on gke security
she used to be I guess you know what I'm
doing now is so so you still in the key
management system I took over for her so
in case you can't tell us apart she said
you know she's one more hair and so that
that's the main we can do it and I'm
also no same and this is just basically
my OCD Gnaeus but people like to send
the edges of the rows I'm not sure if
that's for quick exit or whatever else
but yeah probably right so quick
question how many people here are here
to learn more about data at rest as
opposed to transit all right and how
about didn't transit is that more
important well too bad you're in there
both right so so you're going to learn
about the data rest on transit today and
I promise you that you'll learn
something new maybe not necessarily one
or other but hopefully in both and so
when we talk about encryption right we
usually talk about three broad areas so
you talked about data risk which is
typically you know the data that's
stored on disk or when you're not using
it data in transit when you move it
around right over you know networks or
you know from IPC inter-process
communications or in use when the day is
actually loaded into active memory and
it's being used now we're going to cover
rest and transit not so much in use
right now and it's not that I don't want
to talk about in use but you know
currently right now there's not a lot of
great industry solutions around this and
so you know but the rest and trends are
very very mature type of technologies
now when we start talking like
encryption at rest you got to kind of
think about how enterprises approached
encryption so this picture kind of
depicts different types of customer
or enterprise customers so you may have
small customers who basically probably
don't have a lot of need for maybe key
management maybe they are looking to
actually use a default solution that the
cloud provider provides them not sort
like service a they basically take the
encryption mechanism that's provided
with whatever is provided to them and as
they get a little bit bigger they may
decide that hey I want to do my own key
management right I have more complex
scenarios I have more data I have
different keys I need to use and so I
may actually have either my own key
management system off-the-shelf whatever
is available and we use that right and
then you get to like maybe a service C
and this is where you're talking about
the very large corporations they've got
lots and lots of keys right and so when
you have lots of keys then you have to
do a lot of key management and when you
do a lot of key management things get
pretty complex and they may have custom
solutions to handle this in addition to
actually just using the keys to actually
be stored in the kms they may also use
something called an HSM or hardware
security module and how many people here
know what at HSN is wow that's amazing
you guys are in the very right to the
class so they use HSN because it
provides some you know levels of
assurance around you know compliance
security things like that and that makes
it feel really really good know when we
start talking about the Google cloud and
one thing I want I always like to
mention to everyone make sure everyone's
aware is that when you put your data up
into our cloud we always always
encrypted there's no such thing as
unencrypted data arrests right and
there's nothing that you can turn off or
do anything like that it's just
something that we do and there's no
choice around it now the data gets
upload to Google and what we do is we go
through this very elaborate process to
actually protect your data in several
different ways the first thing we do is
that we take the data we break it up
into small chunks no you can think in
the shards or blocks or whatever you
want to think of but they're broken up
into small chunks and for each of those
chunks we generate a random unique a s
key okay and so you may ask why do you
do that well it's obviously it's one of
the obvious reasons is that it reduces a
blast radius so if one of these keys
gets compromised then you don't lose all
your data
lose a small fragment of it and in order
to actually get access to the complete
set of data you have to actually be able
to break all these different keys which
is actually not a trivial thing to do
right
and so each data each chunk of data gets
us own encrypted key and the and this
encrypted piece chunks of data gets kind
of distributed throughout the data
center okay they get replicated and they
get moved around and so you know again
this is also also helps from a security
perspective a loss harddrive isn't
likely not going to lead to anything
catastrophic right your data is not all
collected in one place it's broken up
and distributed across the day Center
and our day Center has many many many
many many many servers right lots and
lots and so that's what happens there
now when you start talking about you
know encryption then it's not the actual
processors in encryption that's hard
it's the key management right everybody
knows this I mean protecting Keys is a
very very hard thing to do and because
no matter how good your encryption is if
someone takes a key then they actually
access your data as simple as that
in our case what we do is that when you
actually have that piece of data we
create this new new key that's
associated with it now that key actually
stays with the data itself and you
obviously don't want to do that in
plaintext because Noah Bennet's even
even stupider than are encrypting but we
then wrap it we encrypted using a
higher-level key that we call the key
encryption key so it makes sense right
data encryption key for the data and
then key encryption key for encrypting
the data I mean the key I'm sorry and
the way that this works is that the the
key encryption key resides in our own
internal key management system and this
key management system was designed to be
very highly scaleable available
everything else it's basically what we
use internally to run Google as well
right so it had to be something back and
you know performing farm well enough to
support the entire Google domain when
the key actually gets protected in there
then the clock is on and the internal
kms also has properties by which to
actually make sure that the the proper
Apple is involved you know like the
services have the proper you know access
to actually access key for this
particular data and I'll
a little bit more about that as well but
let's kind of walk through what happens
when a service access to encrypt a piece
of data so first thing that happens is
that you have three parties here right
you have a service the storage system
and they came and the actual key
management system they all all have to
work together to make things work the
service comes on and says hey I want
this piece of data please give it to me
and so what the storage system does is
that first of all it checks does the
person actually have access to this data
right and if that if they pass this out
I am check then it says okay let me go
and figure out how to do this it will go
and figure out which chunks or
collectively form that data and then
each of those chunks will actually have
its data encryption keys sent over to
the kms to actually go and decrypt right
so that it can actually decrypt the data
so it does that for each of the
different chunks and then once it gets
back the unwrapped key data encryption
key it can then actually accurately put
the data back together and then send it
back to the application well I shouldn't
mention too if you guys have any
questions please prefer to interrupt I'd
rather pass right now yes please
yeah so the question is is that you know
I said that every all data is encrypted
rest but there's documentation of some
things our exceptions so I should
clarify when I say data I mean customer
data we make a distinction between
customer data and metadata and things
like logs and and you know information
around the data is considered metadata
which we don't necessarily ensure
they're encrypted that that's true but
we try to make sure that there's nothing
in terms of cents of data that's
actually placed into these logs right
now if you actually do something where
you actually you know name name certain
objects with with the sensor information
we advise you not to do that but again
you know we make that distinction and so
you're right but we cannot always
encrypt the metadata for various reasons
okay so now we get down to a little bit
more in terms of key hierarchy and so
this diagram here actually gives you a
fairly good picture of you know how we
do the protect the keys within the
within the storage system and so once we
actually get to the top we've already
discussed that where they have the keys
encrypted and the cloud then kernel KMS
actually is protecting the green keys
there it goes through a whole lab
resistant of different keys that
actually protected you know through
different layers to the point where at
the the second for the bottom right
there you end up with a root kms master
key and this is a key that runs on very
very special machines very you know
highly secured machines in each of the
data centers there's not very many of
them okay they're designed to be very
very reliable and performant and
everything else and there are also meant
to not store the keys on any permanent
media okay so the only existing memory
and there's an internal protocol that
actually shares the keys around so as
long as you have one of these machines
running globally then it'll be able to
recover in case any of these machines
died now in the case where we have a
catastrophic failure like everything
goes you know goes down like you know a
global reset then we do actually keep a
hard copy of that key
put into a physically secure media and
lock them into a physical safe that's
distributed in global aid spirits of set
of locations around the world and there
are very very few people in Google that
actually have access or knowledge of
this I'm definitely not one of them
I'm not considered trustworthy enough
but there's probably less than 20 if I
remember correctly okay now this does a
kind general statement that I'll make
around this is that you know this what
the way we can describe in Christian
arrest by default is a Google and Crips
customer content stored arrest without
any action report from the customer
using one or more unchristian mechanisms
okay so what I described right there is
one of the mechanisms that we use to
actually encrypt your or your data
there's sometimes more at the physical
layer and everything else but you can
rest assured that there's at least you
know your DEA's been encrypted least
once yes
so the question is how do we instantiate
the key that's bootstrapping to memory
right so again as long as one of these
nodes are up and so you have these
specialized nodes that only actually
serve to actually provide this this
hostess root kms master key so there's
basically a sharing protocol that's you
know that's inherent with the system
itself and so they know how to actually
contact one another to actually make
sure that the key gets shared and
propagated throughout the system and so
if there's a new new machine that comes
up then automatically gets shared within
the brand new key it's a little more
elaborate than that I can't get into too
much more details but yes
oh I see so you know when you start from
from zero and you actually want to
actually I'm not sure about that to be
quite honest Majan that there's some
process by which the few people who knew
how to do this would set up and get get
started but I'm not exactly sure yes
question
I'm sorry cuz you repeat that
yes
oh I see so the question is basically
around traceability of where the data
resided yes there's there's both
internal logs that actually keep track
of all the activity that happens in
terms of key management key access and
everything else and then at a higher
level there's also the you know the
cloud auto logging that would actually
actually that's not for this case but
there is actually logging that actually
keeps track of the different accesses
and the different key requests and
everything else so that is all that's
all actually recorded in our internal
logs okay I'm sorry will it appear in
the metadata like do you mean if someone
access to the metadata yeah there would
be logs in case that any key axis right
well it's not necessarily something
that's expose externally going for here
so now we actually get to the point
where we're starting to talk about
things that you can manage yourself so
this is options for encryption at rest
and so when you actually bring up you
know like your data to the cloud we
discussed the first column there which
is a default encryption where you can
actually go and do nothing and we'll
just make sure all your days encrypted
and then the middle we have the customer
management christian keys with cloud KMS
right and that's the case where cloud
KMS is the cloud service that's sort of
the extension external extension of the
key management system and one of the
great great benefits of the kms is that
you can actually have this integrated to
protect with different services so
currently I'll talk a little bit more
about this but if your data resides in
other services then you can actually
associate with a key that you control
under cloud kms and then finally on the
right side we have customer supplied
encryption keys and so this is a feature
that we shipped a couple years ago and
this allows you to actually it's only
built for GCSE and GCE I should mention
as well but this allows you to actually
you know keep the keys resident so you
don't store them in the cloud but every
time you actually make a call that nice
access data you actually provide a
secret that helps unlock that data now
that secret is something that we
actually only keep in memory we don't
actually store to disk ever and so as
soon as you
finish a request we actually purge it
right so there it's only for GC s and GC
GC as I mentioned before it does have
some drawbacks such as no you can't do
anything that's that's offline or you
know like for example we can't do any
kind of backups or or things like
compaction and things like that so it
kind of limits what we can do with the
in terms of the different services ok
now I'll talk really quickly about cloud
KMS as i mentioned it earlier so cloud
KMS is actually the external you know
external key management system and this
is all taken from the website so i won't
spend too much time on this right but it
basically gives you a path by which you
can actually go and create aes-256 keys
and you can manage them yourselves right
you can explicitly say that I want to
create this you know destroy rotate
disable whatever you like with this and
it's because it's a cloud service it's
completely integrated with cloud IM and
cloud otter logging so that means that
you can actually use IM roles to
actually know dictate who can access a
key and what operations they can do and
addition all the operations will be
captured by a cloud cloud auto logging
so whenever someone goes and accesses
the keys for whatever operation then
that would be something that's captured
by the log you know this is just
basically describing some of the things
that if you're familiar with cloud KMS
you already know but you know it's
designed to be a global scalable
performance system it's extremely fast
very very low overhead just because the
way that it works is that you know
there's many many KMS nodes that do a
lot of work and so it it means that you
know when you actually do encryption it
actually doesn't really mealy impact the
performance of the system and then this
is something that that's probably
interesting to a lot of people what's
new asymmetric keys we are finally
introducing a symmetric keys for cloud
KMS okay so the other slide a couple
slides ago i said it does symmetric key
that was a case until this morning we
just announced that we're providing a
cloudy HSM in along with cloudy HSM
we're also providing the ability for you
to actually go into asymmetric key
operations on both hardware and saw
we're and we're allowing you to do
several different types of types of keys
okay so you can actually use RSA 2 K 3 K
4 K you can use that both for signing
and you can use that for decryption and
then we'll also provide you with
elliptic curve keys with a couple than
this curves P 2 5 6 and 3/4 so you can
use those for for signing purposes we've
also expanded since since last year to
multiple regions so very very recently
we expand it to Finland London Frankfurt
Netherlands and then Tokyo Mumbai Sydney
Montreal LA and San Paulo ok another
thing that's really cool is that we are
now supporting multi regions so if
you're familiar we had a multi region
before Bo's one multi-region it was
global right so either you chose a
specific region or you chose the whole
entire world and for some reason some
people didn't like that so we're
providing you with the ability to
actually choose individual regions so
you can either choose the Europe Asia or
u.s. multi regions ok and it's just
basically a very very simple thing when
you create the keyring and finally I
just mentioned this a little while ago
but where we're providing HSM backing
for cloud KMS ok so this is a this is a
very very fantastic news I've been
working very hard on this for the last
couple years so it's been my life for a
little while so I feel very very happy
and sad at the same time but it it's
basically a managed HSM service that
allows you to actually go and do crypt
operations create protect prediction of
your keys and the FIPS 140 - to a level
3 device and if you think that's gonna
be hard to manage well you don't have to
do anything except know how to use cloud
kms and it's just a simple flag when you
created you say I want to create this an
HSN and we just take care of the rest
for you essentially ok
it's an HSM which means that when you
create the keys in there we can't
extract the key material ok we actually
really don't have the capabilities of
actually doing it and you know the keys
are actually bound to a region itself
when you create the keys and say US
central one then the HSM hardware and us
such from one is the thing that binds
and creates and binds our keys to that
regions so even if the key backup gets
moved around it can't be you
anywhere else okay I have a whole
session on this tomorrow at 10:20 and so
if you're interested about this please
drop by I'll talk a lot more about the
hsm stuff and do a lot more demos and
stuff like that where you can see how it
works okay all right I'm gonna I see
people taking pictures so three two one
and finally customer magic encryption
keys if you guys haven't used this yet
you know you should really consider it's
it's great it essentially allows you to
use the corruption that we provide into
the different services protected using a
key that you control in cloud kms right
and because cloudy HSM is integrated
cloud kms you can also use an HSM key as
well if you disappear if you feel like
having some tighter controls around the
availability of the keys and so
currently right now we have this
available for bigquery that's fully GA
the compute engine cloud storage data
proc they're all in beta right now and
so you're free to try this out for with
both software and hardware keys there's
a talk at least for the GCS happening
tomorrow Thursday at 10:20 a.m. the same
time I hear the HSN talk is a little bit
better but but if you're interested in
GCS then please feel free to actually go
and attend this session learn a little
bit more I don't think they're going to
talk to exclusively about this but
they'll mention it and with that I think
I'm going to turn it over to my
predecessor Maya so here you go my can't
have nice things
did I turn it off we're good
great thanks Alison unfortunately I'm
not as funny as Elsa I'm sorry
in advanced and also I talk very fast so
we'll see how this goes so the other
thing if in case you missed something
ounce one set else like mentioned go
check out the blog we post all the
security announcement a couple hours ago
including cloudy HSM if you're not
familiar with that so I'll be talking
about encryption and transit at Google
and how that works so if you're if
you're not familiar and to understand
how encryption in transit works at
Google we first need to understand how
traffic moves to Google and then inside
Google so there are five kinds of
different writing requests here they're
numbered on the slide from the end-user
to the Google to a Google service from
the end-user to a customer application
hosted on Google from a virtual machine
to a Google service from a virtual
machine to another virtual machine and
from a service to another service so the
distinction here our service is a hosted
service like a like a bigquery or cloud
ml etc versus a VM is a VM endpoint has
an IP address like GCE gke or Google
managed VM like COD sequel is so number
one here from the end-user to Google to
a Google cloud service for example if
your users can I think a big query to
run a query Google cloud services accept
requests from around the world using a
globally distributed system called the
Google front end or GFE and the GFC will
terminate incoming HTTP TCP and TLS
proxy traffic provide DDoS attack
countermeasures and route and load
balance traffic to the to the right
Google cloud service there are GP points
of presence around the globe so they
proxy that traffic internally by writing
the users request over our network
backbone to the right spot - from the
end-user to a customer application host
on Google Cloud this is actually the
most complicated case so hopefully we
don't have to talk through some of the
examples that you have so this depends
on how your traffic is routed through
the Internet to your custom application
if you're using a Google cloud load
balancer you can use it to terminate
HTTP TLS and TCP traffic and it's
actually implemented by the Geo fees so
that's why you'd have the same the same
parallel set of options there for HTTP
load balancers connections between end
users or
Crypton authenticated with TLS or quick
using certificates that you provide some
other options if you're connecting using
Cod VPN you connect from your host on
your VM on-premises to the on-prem VPN
to the cloud VPN to the cloud VPN and
the the connection between the 2 VPNs is
protected using IPSec we'll talk a
little bit more about that if you're
connecting to a v8 from the - directly
to an external IP for a VM that
connection does not go through the GFE
and it is not encrypted and protected
the same way that a connection to the
GFE is so if you're serving something
with directly from an IP endpoint that's
your responsibility to protect and
encrypt that traffic similarly if you're
using cloud dedicated interconnect for
example to peer between your on-premises
and Google cloud that also does not go
through the GFE and so it's also your
responsibility to protect that for
example by implementing some application
layer encryption from a virtual machine
so that those 2 for 3 from a virtual
machine to Google Cloud Service it's
actually just reduces to a to another
case which is it will go it will connect
to gf8 will route that request for
example from compute engine VM to Google
Cloud Storage as if it were an external
request and gets into the GFE then GFE
will then do their load balancing and
routing internally for that from a
virtual machine to a virtual machine
that connects over a network backbone
uses using private RFC 1918 IP addresses
and from a Google cloud service to
another Google cloud service also goes
over our private network backbone we'll
talk a little about what we do for both
of those in a second so - here we go to
get us started here you know our
networking team is amazing and all the
stuff that you saw there was kind of
crazy but I'm a security person so I
care about how that traffic is protected
how does it all those five different
things are protected so first from the
user to the front end it travels over
the open Internet and then I'll talk
more about how we protect that on the
site in a second
then once the chat your traffic is
inside Google's infrastructure your data
travels over our private network
backbone and might go to multiple
physical locations in order to fulfill
that request so how is our network
backbone protected it's really important
here to understand that Google applies
different protections
to data in transit when it's transmitted
outside of a physical boundary
controlled by on behalf of Google
compared to when and stays inside
Google's physical boundaries so what do
I mean by this a physical boundary is
the barrier to a physical space that is
controlled by on behalf of Google where
we can ensure that there are rigorous
security measures in place physical
boundaries physical access these
locations is restricted and have we
monitored only a small percentage of
Google employees can can have access to
that hardware and because we tightly
control that space data in transit
within these physical boundaries is
generally authenticated but is not
necessarily encrypted now compare that
to the scale of the global Internet are
everything in our wide area network we
just can't put the same physical
security controls in place right we
can't put like a Google employee
standing every 10 feet of some fiber
optic cable under the sea making sure
that that's all it's all secured so
anywhere outside our physical boundaries
that we aware we can't control that that
link we assume that any network crossing
a physical boundary can be compromised
by an active adversary who could snoop
injector ultra traffic on that wire in
order to ensure data integrity and
privacy we use encryption when data
moves outside physical boundaries so
those under C network cables encrypted I
want to repeat this because it's really
the key takeaway here before I get into
details based on our threat model data
Google and Crips and authenticates data
in transit when that data moves outside
physical boundaries but whereas data
within a physical boundary is generally
authenticated but not always encrypted
all right so now that we have the
high-level picture let's talk through
some of the different scenarios both to
the Google front end and then within
Google's infrastructure add multiple
Network layers so as I mentioned we flee
earlier your data can travel from the
user to the front end in a few different
ways let's take the most simple case
where it talks to your user and you
connect to the to a Google cloud service
so in this case the Google front end
like I mentioned will terminate your
your connection and provide encryption
using HTTP protocol with a public
certificate the GFE will negotiate a
particular encryption protocol with the
client depending on what the clients
able to support the GFE will negotiate a
more modern infection protocol where
possible TLS and the GFE is implemented
using boring SSL which is a Google
maintained open source implementation of
the TLS protocol forked from open SSL
and is mostly interface compatible with
OpenSSL Google's an industry leader in
both the adoption of TLS and the
strengthening of its illumination we've
enabled many of the security features of
TLS for example since 2011 we have been
using forward secrecy in our TLS
implementation forward secrecy makes
sure that the key that protects a
particular connection is not persisted
so that if that connection is
compromised if an attacker can intercept
a particular message they can't read
previous messages that you've sent over
the same connection as part of TLS a
server must prove its identity identity
to the user when it receives a
connection request by having the server
present a certificate containing its
claimed identity this certificate is
signed by an issuing certificate
authority or CA that's trusted by the
user requesting the encryption
historically Google operated its own
issuing CA which is what gives you the
certificates and we use these two signed
certificates for Google domains but
recently Google's also started operating
our own route CA so the route CAS sign
the other smaller CAS that operate
across the Internet today are CA server
certificates that are cross signed by
multiple routes which Arabic ously
distributed so to summarize when you
connect to Google the Google front-end
terminates your traffic encryption is
implemented using boring SSL and
certificates or cross signed including
by Google owned route CAS
now let's get into our network now that
your your request is inside Google's
infrastructure
I might have to travel between Google
locations there we have protections in
place place both at the network layer
and at the application layer let's start
the network layer this layer Google
clouds virtual network authenticates all
traffic between virtual machines this
authentication is a moment in using a
system that we call security tokens
which protect a compromised host from
spoofing packets on the network security
tokens are each max negotiated for a
given sender and receiver pair so a
sender VM and a receiver VM will each
have their own set of tokens during
authentication security tokens are
encapsulated in a tunnel header which
contains authentication information
about the sender and the receiver the
control plan on the serving side sets
the token and the receiving host
validates the token furthermore Google
clouds virtual network infrastructure
enables encryption when traffic goes
outside physical boundary
like I was saying before encryption
applies to private IP traffic within the
same virtual private cloud or between
peered EPC networks we used the advanced
encryption standard in Galois counter
mode a Galois counter mode with 128-bit
key to implement encryption of the
network layer each pair of communicating
hosts establishes a session K via a
control channel protected by alt s which
I'll talk about in a second and for
authenticated encrypted communications
the session key is used to encrypt all
VM to VM communication between these
hosts going up to the application layer
the protection story is very similar
although the implementation is different
at the application layer within Google's
infrastructure we use applications layer
transport security or alt s for the
authentication integrity and encryption
of Google RPC calls this includes RPC
calls from the GFE to a service and from
a service to another service alt s uses
service accounts for authentication each
service that runs in Google's
infrastructure has a service account
identity with associated cryptographic
credentials which it can use for
authenticating itself to other services
when making or receiving our pcs from
other services it uses that service
account to authenticate itself to
provide its its credentials alts will
verify these credentials using an
internal certificate authority within a
physical boundary controlled by Google
LT s provides both authentication and
integrity for our pcs for traffic over
the when outside of physical boundaries
LTS furthermore enforces encryption for
infrastructure RPC traffic automatically
alt s is also used to encapsulate other
layer 7 protocols such as HTTP this
protection ensures that our applicate
this isolates the application layer
removes any dependency on the network
path services can also be configured to
only accept and send a eltis
communication when encrypted even within
physical boundaries notable examples
within Google are our internal team
management system that Ellison was
describing earlier in cloud kms both of
which only accept encrypted
communications let's dig a little bit
deeper into how a LTS works
Google's application layer transport
security or alts
is a mutual authentication and
and transport encryption system
developed by Google and typically used
for securing remote procedure
communications our pcs within our
infrastructure
LTS a similar in concept to mutual TLS
if you're familiar with how that works
or any handshake protocol really but has
been designed and optimized to meet the
needs of Google's data center
environments the LTS trust model was
purpose-built for cloud like
containerized opera applications this is
a key point identities are bound to
entities like a service account not
bound to a specific server name or host
like an IP address this trust model
makes it really easy for us to replicate
load balance and reschedule micro
services across hosts sounds a lot like
it's 2u alts relies on two protocols the
handshake protocol to establish a
session key which you see at the top
there and a second protocol the record
protocol to send their protected RPC
these protocols govern how sessions are
established authenticated encrypted and
resumed
so first the handshake protocol it's a
defeat all men based authentication key
exchange that supports both perfect
chord secrecy and session resumption
during a handshake the client and the
server will negotiate a shared transit
encryption key and the specific protocol
that they're going to use for encryption
and then the record protocol sends the
data often encrypts enough indicates
network traffic using the protocol
secret that was established in the
handshake we published a white paper
explaining exactly how a LTS works on
our website so please do check that out
if you're interested so let's summarize
what we've seen so far and apologies for
these being on two different slides so
first what happens at layer 3 and the
network layer we've covered what
protections we have in place by default
you know we mentioned that we have a
virtual network authentication between
the GFE to the VM and between VMs and we
have encryption when that data crosses
physical boundaries um I also want to
point out it's not that we don't have
any protection from the user to a
front-end or from the user to VM but
that's not at layer 3 that's a layer 7
so I get asked often is there any point
where my data isn't encrypted in transit
what are my options you know what can I
do at this network layer you know in
addition to this production that we
already have if you need additional
protection from the user to the VM or
between the VMS you can use an IPSec
tunnel
how do you set that up you can use cloud
VPN to set up an IPSec tunnel to
securely connect your on-premises
network to your who cloud VPC you have
the option of setting up the you also
quit you can also set up a VPN between
two V pcs this means that your traffic
would go from your on from host to your
on from VM to the cloud VPN sorry from
your on from host to your on-prem VPN to
your cloud VPN to your cloud vm so
there's three hops there that it's
making right from your on-prem host to
your on-prem VPN that's on your network
it's protected like you infect any other
traffic in your environment from the
on-premises VPN to the cloud VPN that's
protected using an IPSec tunnel and from
the cloud VPN to the cloud VM that's
protected by our virtual network as we
previously explained so to set up a VPN
you first have to set up a VPN
on-premises then you can create a cloud
VPN gateway and tunnel on the hosted
services VPC network and permit traffic
between the networks you can further
customize your network by specifying the
internet key exchange version for your
VPN tunnel ika v1 and ikev2 each of
which supports different ciphers if you
specify ikv one google with the packets
using AES advanced encryption standard
in cipher block in cipher block chaining
mode with 128-bit key and provides
integrity using a sha-1
h Mac if you're using ikev2 you have a
variety of ciphers that are available to
you and supported and in all cases
Google Cloud VP animals negotiate the
most secure option available between the
peer devices an alternative to an IPSec
tunnel I mentioned briefly earlier would
be to use something like Google Cloud
dedicated in to interconnect to connect
from your on-premises to Google Cloud in
that case it provides direct physical
connections using RFC 1918 addresses
between your network and Google's
network the data traveling over this
connection is not encrypted by default
and it's your protection to secure this
it's your it's your responsibility to
secure this and we'd recommend for
example application layer encryption for
example using TLS so that was at the
network level
let's look up at the at the application
layer again as you recall we use TLS to
encrypt data from the user to the Google
front end and also from a VM to the
Google front end because that's how we
write travel I wrote traffic back
through the GFC and then we use alt s
within
infrastructure between services for
authentication integrity and furthermore
encryption between physical locations to
avoid confusion I also want to point out
here that VM to VM traffic it's not that
it's not protected again it's protected
to layer a layer 3 if you need
additional network layer protections
from the user to the GFE we have a
couple of AA different options including
managed SSL Certificates for your user
applications and in Gmail you can use s
mime and within Google's infrastructure
if you need additional services service
protections you can use Sto so let's
quickly to dive into what these these
provide when building an application on
Google cloud you can leverage the gfu
support of TLS by configuring the SSL
certificate that you want to use for
example you could have the TLS session
terminate in your application as well
google provides free and automated ssl
certificates in both firebase hosting
and Google App Engine custom domains
these certificates are only available
for Google hosted properties once your
domain is pointed at Google's
infrastructure we request one and obtain
a certificate for that domain to assure
to ensure - sorry - allow secure
communications we manage this TLS server
private keys on your behalf which are
either 2048 bit RSA or SEC P 256 r1 ECC
and we're new certificates on your
behalf as well for Gmail specifically
Gmail already uses TLS by default so in
fact Gmail actually records and displays
whether the last hop that an email made
was over a TLS session when a gmail user
exchanges an email with another gmail
user the emails are protected by TLS
with the exception of if they're sent
directly within the application they're
protected with alt s as we described
earlier for incoming messages from other
email providers Gmail doesn't enforce
the use of TLS if this is a requirement
for you as a gmail admin you can go
configure Gmail to require secure TLS
connection for all incoming and outgoing
emails if you have stronger Enterprise
requirements for secure multi-purpose
internet mail extensions or s/mime which
is an email security standard that
provides authentication integrity and
encryption for your emails then you can
implement that in Gmail as well the
implementation of s/mime standard
mandates that certificates associated
with users sending emails are hosted in
a public CA if this if you have this
requirement as a gmail admin you can
configure Gmail to enable
mine for outgoing emails setup policies
for content and attachment compliance
and create routing rules for incoming
and outgoing emails the last additional
production will quickly cover is Sto SCO
is an open source service mesh that
provides a uniform way to connect
monitor and secure services the trend
towards micro services and
containerization in general is leading
to more complicated applications that
are more difficult to monitor and why
I'm excited about continuous security
these days sorry ill son sto supports
managing traffic flows between micro
services enforcing access policies and
IRA gating telemetry data and all of
that without having to change our
application so it's a complete godsend
in that regard
given Google's experience with alts sto
it's a logical extension of what we've
already built and what we've done in
developing micro services for over 15
years
like alts sto issues and identity which
is a certificate for every service
running in the mesh is to then
transparently adds mutual TLS to all
service calls based on these identities
providing authentication and integrand
encryption across your services there
are lots of talks on this conference at
this confrontation so I won't dig into
it there was one yesterday honesty of
security so check out that recording
online so to sum it all up for data
encryption in transit Google encryption
authenticates data in transit at one or
more network layers the network layer
and the application layer when data
moves outside physical boundaries not
controlled by on behalf of Google and if
you want to learn more I've spent some
large amount of my career writing
niche-y papers you can go check them out
learn more about encryption in transit
encryption at rest what I'll sing and I
talked about today thank you so much for
your time
[Music]